ostern herrlich da setze ich mir immer
meine hasenohren auf schenk mir ein
großes glas eierlikör ein und gehen
nicht in die kirche mache ich seit
meiner kindheit so schon als west china
habe ich karfreitags immer den
gottesdienst geschwänzt habe mich vor
die kirche gestellt und gegen die weiter
protestiert ab sowieso nie kapiert was
ich in der kirche soll ist jesus ostern
in die kirche gegangen
ich glaube nicht und ja natürlich habe
ich das freitags vormittags gemacht
sonst wird man ja nicht gehört und
deshalb finde ich es super dass
jugendliche freitags nicht zur schule
gehen sondern auf die straße mit ihrer
aktion fff [ __ ] für den frieden
friday is for future wir haben damals
gegen pasching raketen demonstriert die
die welt theoretisch zerstören konnten
die jugendlichen heute demonstrieren
gegen einen klimawandel der die welt
ganz real zerstört kann man nichts gegen
sagen trotzdem flippen alle aus die
sollen mal lieber in die schule gehen
das hat ein lernen die verwöhnten box
löffel warum es fällt doch sowieso jede
zweite stunde wegen lehrermangel aus
dann helfen sie freitags immer nicht der
vertretungslehrerin im letzten
funktionierenden overheadprojektor von
1982 die birne zu wechseln
christian lindner ist fassungslos
goldene regel wenn christian lindner
fassungslos ist dann hat man alles
richtig gemacht
lieber 1000 krieter tun werks als einen
christian lindner und meine lieblings
schwachmaten kritik die stellen ja nur
forderungen die horden gar keine
konkreten ideen natürlich nicht sind
teenager teenager gehirne können nur
zwei dinge die eine hälfte findet alles
scheiße
der andere ist ständig geil
aber das heißt ja nicht dass sie nicht
recht haben mit dem klimawandel
okay wenn man unbedingt über junge leute
meckern will in eurem alter habe ich
noch nicht so viele co2 verballert meine
generation ist vorher nicht übers
wochenende zum saufen nach halle
geflogen
ich war das erste mal auf malle da war
ich schon über 40 mit meiner frau
außerdem der klimawandel hat auch
vorteile zum beispiel war 2018 ein top
weinjahrgang durch die viele sonne
da muss man prioritäten setzen venedig
versinkt guter riesen schwierig trotzdem
frei die software macht genauso weiter
ich muss mich jetzt auch fertig machen
für meine nächste demo
man ist für mariana peace out
hans de schreibt über die heute show ihr
seid die richtigen links [ __ ]
besonders welke die stradivari unter den
arschgeigen bei euch smileys
freudentränen freudentränen
freudentränen freund rimkus mit herz
vielen dank für ihr freundliches flugweg
für ein exklusives geigensolo von oliver
welke
abonnieren sie den kanal